SRINI DEVADAS:
Morning, everyone.
Welcome to 6.S095.
Thanks for registering
for this class.
I hope you like it.
My name is Srini Devadas.
I'm a professor of computer
science at MIT, obviously,
and I've been teaching
at MIT for 30 years.
So I've been at it for a while.
The reason I'm
teaching this IAP class
is because I want to try
out this way of teaching
programming that starts
with the recreational world
of mathematical puzzles,
algorithmic puzzles,
and I want to connect it
up to writing programs.
And I have taught this
material before in 6.009
that I think some of
you are registered for,
but I wanted to teach it
in a more interactive,
informal setting.
And I should mention
that I wrote a book
on this, which is a book
that's recommended, though not
required, for 6.009.
And so you might see
this in the MIT Press
Bookstore and other places.
And most of the material
I'm going to cover here
is from the book.
But I don't want
you to read the book
because I want you to listen to
my explanations for the puzzles
and try and think
of the solutions
yourself and then obviously
do some amount of coding
not during lecture but offline.
And I'll show you some
solutions to the puzzles,
and there will be
some exercises.
So I don't want to spend a
whole lot of time on logistics.
This is an IAP class,
as I mentioned.
I'd like this to be
informal and relaxed.
So we meet every
day for two weeks.
We have the holiday
coming up on Monday,
so we'll have nine total
lectures roughly for an hour.
It might spill over, but
hopefully, you'll be OK with it
because you don't have another
class to go to at noon.
And if you do,
well, let me know,
and I'll give you that
five minutes of overflow
personally at a time
of your choosing.
But hopefully,
I'll keep on time.
And in terms of work,
this is a pass/fail.
It's a for-credit class.
I know some of you may be
listeners, but some of you
are registered for it.
So I'll have to
assign you a grade,
so there will be some exercises.
And I'm going to
make it very simple.
There'll be exercises
up on the website.
They'll be due two days
from when I put them up.
And you'll have options
in terms of whether to do
a really simple
exercise that's probably
going to take about five
minutes or do something harder.
And for each of
the puzzles, there
are two or three exercises,
and you get to do all of them
if you want.
You can choose to
do one or the other.
I'm going to have office hours
every day from 1:00 to 2:00.
I don't plan on putting
solutions up to the exercises.
The solutions to the
puzzles themselves,
they'll be shown
mostly in lecture
and put up on the
Stellar website,
but the solutions
to the exercises,
I'm not going to put up.
But if you ever get
stuck, well, that's
what office hours are for.
And if you can't
solve the exercises,
I'll help to solve them.
So with that,
without further ado,
let's dive in and
talk about puzzles
and solving puzzles using
algorithms and then programs.
I'd really like this
to be interactive,
so please ask questions
and suggest solutions
that I haven't thought of.
That'd be great.
In my second edition,
whenever that is,
you'll get credit for that.
So the first puzzle, I
tried to have, I don't know,
funny titles for all
of these puzzles--
intriguing.
And so the first puzzle is
called "You Will All Conform."
This is really a warm-up puzzle.
As you'll see-- this
is true for any class--
things are going to get more
complicated as we go along.
So we'll probably do 10 or 12
puzzles in the next two weeks.
And by the end, you're going
to see things like memoization
and dynamic
programming and things
like that towards
the end of next week.
And if you don't know
what those mean, well,
that's great because
hopefully, you
will know by the end
of the two weeks.
And a lot of these things
are algorithmic insights,
are insights that will help you
in Course 6 classes, for sure,
and perhaps even if you follow
a career outside of Course 6.
So this particular puzzle is, as
I said, a fairly simple puzzle,
at least to describe.
And the setting is as follows.
So you're a gatekeeper
at a baseball game.
We'll just call
it a baseball game
because baseball
players wear caps,
and most people are
watching games with caps on.
And so you're a gatekeeper,
and there are a bunch
of people standing in line.
Let's just say each of
them knows their number.
And this is Python,
so the number
starts at 0 as opposed to 1.
And there are a
whole bunch of people
standing in line waiting to
get in, and they all have caps.
And some of them are
wearing their caps forward,
so with the--
I guess, what do you call it?
What's the front
of the cap called?
The shade-- the thing that
gives you shade up front.
And so we just say--
let me try and draw this out.
So this person is wearing
his cap like that,
and this lady here is
wearing her cap like this.
So that's forwards,
and that's backwards.
So your job here
is straightforward.
You can only let all of
these people into line--
sorry-- into the stadium who
are in line if they all conform.
So they all have
to wear their caps
in a particular orientation,
and you don't particularly
care which one.
And so they all
have to be forwards,
all, let's say, 13 of them.
Or they all have
to be backwards.
Now, all of them know
their position on the line.
So this person knows
that his position is 0,
this lady here knows
that her position
is 1, et cetera, et cetera.
And so obviously, you'd like
to minimize the amount of work
that you do, and you
could certainly choose--
let's say you want
everyone to be forwards.
You could say, hey, lady in
position 1, flip your cap.
Oh, I should mention
something that is important.
So people have a
different definition
of forwards and backwards.
It's sort of what's natural
and what's unnatural to them.
So we think that this person
has his cap on forwards.
But for all you know, he
thinks he's got his cap
on backwards or vice versa.
So you can't assume
that the definition
of "forwards" and "backwards" is
identical for all of the people
in line and really is the
same as your definition.
It seems kind of unreasonable.
Hey, this is a puzzle, so
let's not argue about that.
We can argue about other
things, like how to write
Python programs properly.
So what you have
to do now is you
have to call out commands
that correspond to saying,
person in position
0, flip your cap.
That's all you can say.
You can just say, flip your cap.
You can obviously see how
these caps are oriented,
and you can ask--
let's say that you had
something like that.
I'm just making this up as
I go along, in terms of I'm
not going to draw
all the caps here.
But this is what it looks like.
And so according to you,
you see F, B, B, in terms
of Forwards and Backwards.
And let's say you decide
that you want everyone
to have their cap on forwards.
Then you could say, person
in position 1, flip your cap.
Person in position
2, flip your cap.
And then person in
position 4, 7, et cetera.
And you want to make
it easier on yourself
because people do know their
indices, their positions
in line.
And so to save
yourself some trouble,
you could say, people in
positions 1 through 2--
and the implication is that
it's inclusive-- flip your caps.
And so that takes
care of these two.
And perhaps 8 here and 9
had their caps on backwards,
and you could say, people
in positions 7 through 9,
flip your caps.
So in this particular
example, assuming
that things ended with 10
people in line, 0 through 9,
you could get away
with three commands.
You could say, 1 through 2--
and the implication, as I
said, is this is inclusive--
flip.
And then you could say, 4, flip.
And then you could
say, 7 through 9, flip.
And if you did it
the other way, you
could also say,
person at 0, flip,
and so this would go backwards.
Person at 3, flip.
Obviously, you can't
say, 0 through 3
because that would be wrong.
And then you could
say 5 through 6 here.
So you would get three
commands in that case, as well.
But if in fact, for
argument's sake, let's
just say that I'm going
to just turn this into 10
and put an F down here.
Then these three
commands would still
work if you wanted to focus
on the B's, on the Backwards
people, and make them
make them go forwards.
But if you wanted to make
all of the forward people
go backwards, you would need
1, 2, 3, 4, four commands.
So in this particular
case, you're
better off doing that as
opposed to doing four commands.
So first straightforward
question is--
and I'm not talking
about code yet--
algorithmically, just
in terms of pseudocode--
and I'm happy with English--
how would you determine the
minimum set of commands given
a particular set of people?
There's an arbitrary
set of people.
You want to make sure that you
have the absolute minimum set
of commands, and you're going
to have to use these intervals.
So you definitely
want to look for all
the contiguous intervals
because obviously,
if you say 1 followed and then
that's a separate command, then
you say 2 and that's
a separate command,
you end up having more
commands than necessary.
So anyone want to tell
me I guess roughly,
in terms of pseudocode,
how this would work?
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Well, you
could go down the line
and look at the groups.
So start with the 0.
You've got to write 0.
Group them.
And then whatever
the second one is--
so whatever the second
group is, if it's F or B,
those are the ones
that need to be flipped
because that's going to be the
minimum number of commands.
And then so from what
you pass through,
whenever you get to those,
you just tell them to flip.
SRINI DEVADAS: Sounds good.
Do you have anything
to add to that?
AUDIENCE: No.
I was going to say, you
find the backwards interval
or forward interval.
And whichever is
the lower, then--
SRINI DEVADAS: Lower.
That's good.
Good.
Excellent.
And so both of you had it right.
So let me explain what these two
gentlemen-- what was your name?
AUDIENCE: Ganatra.
SRINI DEVADAS: Ganatra?
Yours?
AUDIENCE: Fadi.
SRINI DEVADAS: Fadi?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SRINI DEVADAS: So
Ganatra and Fadi said--
so basically, this
is, as I said,
the natural algorithm
that you would use.
The natural algorithm
would be that you
walk through this
list, and you start
computing what I would
call-- you called it
"groups," Ganatra.
But I'd call them
"intervals," and an interval
is something that is unbroken.
It's contiguous.
It's a contiguous
set of people who
all have their caps in
the same orientation,
be it forward or backwards.
And what you would do in this
case is you would compute the--
you would say, I want to look
at the forward intervals.
And the forward
intervals would be 0,
0 because that's essentially
what you have in here.
And going through that
list, you would also say,
I'm going to be computing
the backward intervals.
And in this case, you discover
1, 2 as the backwards interval.
So I'm going to write
them out like that.
And in general, in the
mathematical notation,
when you put square brackets,
these are closed intervals.
So 0 is included.
And we're going to
see a puzzle where
you might see something
a little bit different,
so I wanted to point that out.
So 1, 2 are both
inside this interval.
And these two you
would generate as you
would go through the
list, and then you
would generate 3, 3 over here.
And then you would generate 4--
yeah, that's right, just 4--
I'm sorry, 4, 4
over here, if you
want to call it an interval.
You could represent
this differently.
There's nothing that
stopping you in Python
to have these slightly more
complicated representations
where you just have
0 here as a number.
And if it's just
a number, then it
represents an
interval of length 1,
but let's just be
uniform about this.
Usually, when you
have special cases
and if you do things
heterogeneously,
then you have more
code to write.
It might get more efficient,
but there's usually
more code to write.
So you do 4, 4 here.
And then you'd go up, and
then you'd have 5 comma 6.
And then you would do 7 comma--
I'm sorry, 7 comma 9.
So this is the first
time you actually
have something interesting, in
the sense that the interval has
a representation that only
has two numbers in it,
whereas you actually have
three people in that interval.
And obviously, this
could be arbitrarily
large in the context of people
getting into a baseball game--
and so 7 through 9 and then
finally here 10 through 10.
And so now you go
ahead, and you count
and you realize that there's
four intervals here and three
intervals here.
And then you say, I'm
going to go ahead and go
with the backwards and asking
the people who are-- well,
according to you-- backwards
to flip their caps so we're all
good.
So I'm going to show
you code that implements
exactly this algorithm.
And while you see
the code, I want
you to think about
this harder question.
This code is going to do
exactly what we describe.
It's going to go compute
all of these things,
and as you can
imagine, he's going
to make a pass through
this entire Python
list, this group of people,
this queue of people,
and is going to do
this computation.
Then it's going to say,
4 is greater than 3.
And then it's going to go
through and start calling out
commands for each of
the backward intervals.
So in some sense, it's going to
make two passes over the list.
So the first pass is to get
all of the intervals together.
Then there's a check.
And then the second
pass is to take
those backward
intervals, in this case,
and call out those commands.
So that's what I
mean by two passes.
Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: You don't
necessarily need to count them,
the 4 and 3 because whichever
orientation interval comes
second is always going--
SRINI DEVADAS: Brilliant.
Brilliant.
So I was going to say--
if you didn't
understand what Ganatra
said, wonderful because then
you can think about the question
I'm going to ask and
ignore what he said.
And then we'll get to, I
guess, the more efficient code.
But what I was going to ask was,
is there a way that I'm looking
at this, and I'm just going--
and I'm going to just start
calling out by--
the moment I see that there's
an interval, the moment I see--
this is an interval.
And I'm going to make
a call with respect
to whether I'm going to
call out a command or not.
And I'm going to do this in
one pass through this array.
I want to do this in one
pass through the array.
I want to look at this, and I
say, I see the interval 0, 0.
Is that going to
be something that I
need to worry about in
terms of that person
having to flip his cap?
And then I see B, B. And I say,
oh, the interval is 1 comma 2.
Is that something I'm
going to have to deal
with in terms of a command?
And so someone else
other than Ganatra,
tell me if there's a
one-pass algorithm.
And explain to me why you
can do this in one pass
through the array.
And just in terms of
code, I'll preview this.
The first algorithm needs--
according to my coding,
which, isn't great--
26 lines of code.
The second one needs
eight lines of code.
So yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So after you
see the first interval,
you know that the second
interval at the very least
is going to have the same number
of commands as the first one.
So you might as well always
go with the second one.
So once you've
identified what type
the first interval is, you
iterate through the list
seeing--
and once you identify the
first and second intervals,
you iterate through every
type of the second interval
and do a command for that.
SRINI DEVADAS: That's
absolutely right.
What was your name?
AUDIENCE: Kevin.
SRINI DEVADAS: Kevin?
So you had it right.
And Kevin has it right, as well.
So the observation
here is actually--
it was said a little bit
differently by Kevin,
but I'm going to say it
a little bit differently.
The observation is
simply that if you
look at the very
first orientation,
the very first orientation
is something which,
at best, is going to be a tie.
So if you had it ending
with 10 people, 0 through 9,
then the number of
forward intervals
is the same as the number
of backwards intervals.
And if you went here, obviously,
the number of forward intervals
is greater than the number
of backwards intervals.
So you really only have to look
at the first person in line not
to determine the
intervals because when
you see the first
person in line,
you have no idea what
the intervals are
that are coming after.
You have to generate
those intervals,
so you have to make your
pass through the array.
But the first person
in line gives it away
in terms of what
the final result is
going to be with respect
to your decision as to what
set of commands you're
going to call up.
And so because this is an F, you
basically say, I'm going to go,
and I'm going to make the people
with the B's flip their caps.
And that's a small observation
in terms of its insight.
But obviously, it's
potent, in the sense
that it's going to give
you a one-pass algorithm
versus a two-pass algorithm.
And as I mentioned,
it's going to give you
a substantial reduction in the
amount of code that you write.
So I'm going to show
you a bunch of code now.
So this is usually how
this is going to go,
by the way, this entire class.
And this is kind of
my way of teaching,
at least this type of material
that's algorithmic and has
data structures and so on.
I like explaining to
people what they're
going to see in the code without
having to deal with Python
syntax and worrying about
whether it's while loops
or for loops and things like
that and tuples or arrays
and things like that.
So let's get into that.
I don't need this.
Ah, good.
So the naive algorithm first--
so what you see
here is an input.
So "caps" is simply an
input Python list that has,
as you can see from our
examples, the F's and the B's.
And so F is Forwards,
and B is Backwards.
And there are a couple
of different Python lists
so you can run them
with different things.
And all of this hopefully is
not at all surprising to you
because we went
through all of this
in terms of the pseudocode.
So the first initialization--
and I can just highlight
that to make it easy.
So that's initialization.
And this part here--
the comment sort
of gives it away--
is you're making a
pass through the array,
computing the intervals.
And so how do you actually
get the intervals?
And there's one line
of code that does that.
And oh, by the way, if there
are any questions about Python
syntax, just don't feel shy.
Just tell me.
Ask me a question, and
I'm happy to explain it.
I don't want to explain things
that you all know, obviously.
But if any one of you doesn't
know any particular thing,
please don't feel shy.
Syntax is something that
sometimes you even forget.
I tend to forget things.
So this thing here
is essentially
something that decides on
what the intervals are.
And the insight here is simple.
You know that this interval
ended when you see something
here that is different from
what the previous one is.
So that's when you know.
So you generate the interval
when you go and find
something that is different
from the current location
that you're pointing to.
So that's really what's
going on out here.
In this line, you say, you're
setting a "start" here.
"Start" is your counter,
and remember, "start"
is getting set again here.
Initially, it was set to 0.
And if you ever get to the point
where you're looking at "i,"
it's the next thing
you're looking at,
and if "caps start," which
is the start of the interval,
is different from "i," it
meant that the interval that
began with "start" ended.
And so you
essentially say, well,
that needs to end at i minus 1
because obviously, "caps start"
is different from "caps size."
So this is the end of
the interval right here.
And this particular
thing, our interval,
is something that includes
both these two numbers,
so it's not exactly that.
But it also includes--
where did my chalk go?
It also includes whether
this is an F or not.
So each of these things has--
I'm not going to write it
out for all of those things--
but has the orientation
inside of it.
So that's what
you have out here.
That's why we have three
of these in this tuple.
This is a tuple because it's
got round brackets around it.
I could have made it
a list if I wanted.
And so that's essentially
what we have here.
And now, here's what happens.
In this particular piece of
code, when you get to the end
and you fall off the end--
so if you just end, then
this code essentially
skips over and doesn't actually
put in the last interval
because you don't see something.
When you come up here and
you're off the end of the array,
you fall off the
edge of the array,
you don't see a B that
is different from F.
So if you just wrote that code--
so it's something that
I'd say many people would
have a quote, "bug,"
where they wouldn't
add this part of the code here
because they didn't realize
this particular
point that I made.
And so that last interval
doesn't get added in.
And so you have a
bit more code here
that decides on
the last interval.
And then you count, and then you
go ahead and call the commands.
So this all looks good?
Yeah, we're good with this?
Is there a way that
I could somehow
eliminate these four
lines of code which
are a little bit annoying and
just do things in the array?
How could I, with
a little trick,
eliminate those
four lines of code?
I might need a little bit more
in, quote, "pre-processing,"
but how would I eliminate that?
Someone else?
I'll get to you.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: One way is
you can check thoroughly
you've reached the end of the--
the forward is equal
to the backwards.
SRINI DEVADAS: You could
have an extra check.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Kanishka.
SRINI DEVADAS: Kanishka?
So Kanishka says that before
you reach the end of the array
or when you reach
the end of the array,
you go ahead and do a check
that you've reached the end
and generate the interval
inside of it, which
is kind of like moving
this code inside of it.
So that's reasonable.
I'm not sure that's going to be
as good as the way that I want
and which I coded.
Think about pre-processing.
Think about taking
the array-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: I guess you could add
a wrong interval at the end.
SRINI DEVADAS: You could
add on a wrong interval.
What was your name?
AUDIENCE: Kevin.
SRINI DEVADAS: Kevin, too?
Just how many Kevins
do we have here?
So you could do this.
So let me show you something
that's a little bit more--
so that was 26 lines of code.
And so this says--
this is the line
that's interesting.
So I had F and B, and so I
don't want to add F or B there.
But what is convenient
to do, as it turns out,
is to just have something
that essentially says,
there's an ending point.
So you have an explicit end
to the array that is actually
not something that would crash
if you tried to access it.
You had n people in line,
and now you have effectively
n plus 1 people in line.
But that n plus one
person is a dummy,
or you can call them "end."
And then if you do
that, then that's it.
The previous code works.
You can just remove
those four lines,
and it'll all just work
because your F or your B
is not equal to "end."
So whatever you had at the end--
I'm sorry.
I'm overloading terms here.
Whatever you had at
the last element--
whether it was a B because
it ended here or F--
when you equate that
to "end," you're
going to get an inequality.
And so that last
interval gets generated--
so small optimization.
Tony Hoare was a very
famous computer scientist--
said that "inside
every program, there's
a smaller program
waiting to get out."
So this is kind of
one of the themes
that I'd like to harp on in
this class, which is it's
nice to write compact code.
Usually, if you can
write compact code,
there are fewer bugs in it.
And you don't want
to go overboard.
You don't want too
many subtleties,
but it's nice to
write compact code.
And so this is a little
bit more compact.
And then finally, here's
the one-pass algorithm.
So the whole thing, the
"pleaseConformonepass,"
is the smarter algorithm
that essentially says,
look, if I just look at
the very first thing,
I'm going to be able to
skip that and then move on.
So this is fairly complicated.
You know the algorithm.
Trying to map that to
this code is non-trivial,
so we'll spend a
minute or two on it.
But here's how this works.
And by the way,
just to make sure--
so I've repeated things here.
So the optimized algorithm
for that particular example
produced these first
three commands.
And then the one-pass
algorithm produced
exactly the same commands.
So this is good to do.
It's always nice
to have a couple
of different ways
of solving a problem
because then you
can verify things.
Anyway, so this piece
of code is essentially
something that does a similar
trick to what we had before,
in terms of adding
to the original list,
adding an element.
But we're not using "end" here.
We're actually
saying, what we want
to do because we're going to go
ahead and skip this, anyway--
we know we're going
to skip the F.
So whatever that is, we could
just sort of add up here.
And so that makes it easy.
You don't have to worry about
what the actual characters are
and cooking up this
"end," which is different
from the F or the
B because hey, it's
possible that people
might use whatever
they want to represent a
forward cap or a backward cap.
So this is very clean.
You go ahead and put
exactly that over here.
You know you're going to skip
that interval because you're
going to skip the first
interval, effectively,
because that is what the
algorithm allows you to do.
And then this part here is
doing what we had before.
We're not even
generating the intervals.
We're just directly
making the commands.
So there are no tuples
in terms of the tuples
and the appending of the
intervals data structure
that we had.
It's all gone.
I'm just going to go ahead
and fire off these commands.
And those commands are
written in kind of a funny way
because I'm going
to go ahead and if I
wanted to print
these things out,
you'd have to do this
in this funny way.
If you're willing to wait
and collect up the intervals,
you can certainly do that.
But this is absolutely
the most compact code
that I could think of,
and I'm printing a command
in two different parts.
I'm printing the first part
of the command that says,
people in positions.
And that's the start
of the interval "i,"
and I'm just using
a Python construct.
This "end" here is something
that the print command
can recognize.
And this simply says,
don't give me a new line.
I want to print it exactly.
As you saw from
when I ran the code,
the printing was exactly the
same as the original algorithm.
And so this "end" simply
says, don't print a new line
at the end of
people in positions,
whatever this number is.
Call it 7.
And you don't
print the new line.
And then you have a space
here because you didn't
print a new line or a space.
And you go through i minus
1, which is exactly the same
as we had before.
You only discover that the
end of an interval after you
see the person that
comes after the interval.
So you have to go
back to i minus 1.
So this makes sense?
Any questions about this code?
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So the
first line, like
you said, if we're going
to move the first--
SRINI DEVADAS: Not
move, duplicate--
AUDIENCE: Duplicate the first--
SRINI DEVADAS: Yeah.
So the plus there
is a concatenation,
and you have two lists.
"Caps" is a list.
And when you use a plus
operator in Python,
you can only add things
that are of the same type.
And so "caps" is a
list, and "cap 0"
is an element of the list.
And so you need to
make it a list in order
to use the plus operator.
There are also other things
you could do using a pen,
for example.
So you could take that line,
and you could do "caps start"
at "pen" "cap 0."
And you wouldn't need all
of the square brackets,
but that's just
neither here nor there.
But I'm obviously not answering
your question, so go ahead.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I was
going to say that we
skip the first interval.
And then we flip all the
second-type orientation.
SRINI DEVADAS: That's right.
AUDIENCE: But here, we're
focusing on the first element.
Why--
SRINI DEVADAS: Ah, but
that's OK because remember,
the if statement is going
to skip this one, too.
So if I had two F's
in the beginning--
I think your question
is, what would
happen if I had two F's or
three F's in the beginning?
So I'm going to go ahead, and
first thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to put
an F at the end here,
and then maybe there's
a bunch of stuff.
But then the nice thing is
that I'll skip this F, too,
because the not equal
to is not going to fire.
The next line, the "caps
i not equal to i minus 1,"
this is going to be equal to.
So I'm going to go ahead
and go to the next iteration
of the loop.
That makes sense?
Did people understand
Fadi's question?
It was a good question.
So the question was, you
skipped the first one.
But what is making you skip
this one because you want
to skip the first interval?
And so that if statement
is making you do that.
Good.
So as you can see, even a
fairly straightforward puzzle--
this is the simplest puzzle
we're going to do here
is the first one.
And there are nuances
associated with how you solve it
but also how you code it.
And this is kind of--
like I said, this was my
eureka moment a few years ago,
where I said, I
think the way you
want to teach
programming, at least
some aspects of programming,
is in this fashion.
Anyway, good.
So we're done with this.
Any questions about this puzzle?
All right.
Good.